en entrée du coup on aura du chou rouge
en maïs avec une vinaigrette à la
moutarde
après on aura un sauté de boeuf en
garant plat en garniture une pomme de
terre et de l'emmental râpé
il y aura aussi une surprise du coup
pour les enfants en amuse bouche
donc ce sera un toast de pain avec une
rondelle de chèvre et du miel de
chambray et après du coup les enfants
ils pourront voter il y aura une urne au
réfectoire au restaurant ils pourront
voter soit il m soit il aime pas voilà
pour le menu du jour concocté par
ludovic souchaud le nouveau chef gérant
des quatre cuisines scolaires de
chambray-lès-tours ces équipes sont
composées d'agents municipaux
mais lui et le salarié d'une société de
restauration en contrat avec la mairie
et il doit se plier à certaines
obligations
j'ai un cahier des charges où il faut
qu'on soit à 100 % bio souhait de la
mairie de chambre est 100 % bio dont on
a actuellement à 88 % de produits bio
on doit être aussi à 80 % de produits
frais on va tous nos légumes sont frais
voilà les pommes de terre les carottes
pour l'épurer d'aujourd'hui le chou là
on essaye d'avoir un maximum de produits
frais je trouve que le geste de la
mairie de faire du que du bio et de
décès et diminuer les déchets je trouve
tout ça très bien voilà pour les enfants
pour alors pour la future génération je
trouve ça vraiment très très bien depuis
2014 les produits bio ont été introduits
progressivement dans les assiettes des
petits chambraisien l'an dernier il
composait 50% des menus et c'est en
renouvelant son marché de fournitures
alimentaires que la mairie a décidé de
passer au tout bio
enfin c'est un choix politique très fort
de mettre un accent sur la santé
publique sur l'écologie et sur la
qualité du repas servis à nos enfants
nous avons conservé un prix les repas
qui au sein de la métropole fait partie
des prix le repos les plus faibles de
0,35 pour le prix le plus bas et 3 0 5
centime pour le plus élevé parce que
notre prix est fait en fonction du
quotient familial des familles pour
tenir compte de leur situation
financière et sociale 850 repas sont
servis tous
pour six écoles et quatre crèches
auxquels il faut ajouter un centre de
loisirs le surcoût représenté par le
bios s'élève à environ 150 milles euros
par an et il est donc intégralement
prélevés sur le budget communal
le jeu en vaut la chandelle c'est en
tout cas ce que semblent penser les
élèves de l'école élémentaire jean
moulin site une alimentation qui m'épate
on obésité y en danger et bah c'est bon
pour la santé ça donne de la force et
c'est un produit bio c'est toi y'a pas
de produit chez mais qu'est ce qu'on
mange c'est bon j'ai bien ma produits
bio pourquoi c'est important bond
grandir et la mairie de chambre est
aussi voit l'avenir en grand pour
optimiser la gestion et le coût de ces
cantines elle envisage la construction
d'ici à 2020 d'une cuisine centrale
ultra moderne et bien sûr 100 % bio